there's a lot of degrading when it comes
to women because a lot of people really
want what you have and if they can't get
it you kind of become a punching bag and
they love to take it out on you or you
just get comments that a lot of guys
don't get who are you sleeping with you
must be sleeping with a manager you must
be married to some rich person who's
buying you all this product it has
nothing to do with the work ethic that
you have behind your content I think
I've had that tough skin already built
within me and so I think because of that
it's allowed me to just look past those
comments and really just keep pushing
the Forefront for women to try to be a
part of the community and creete content
like me cuz we really do need more of us
out there